let's talk about what fear leads to so
we have this story from the atlantic
america is running out of everything the
global supply chain is slowing down at
the very moment when americans are
demanding that it go into overdrive for
the longest time they said the economy
is actually recovering there's just too
much demand now they're back to actually
yeah it's collapsing now what happens is
in the early days we they said 15 days
to slow the spread and people said okay
15 days i'm fine with that then they
started saying look at the numbers look
at the numbers cnn i don't think it's a
grand conspiracy i think what happens is
cnn knows it's gangbusters in the
ratings when they get that ticker on the
screen showing dead people regular
people then panic put on 80 masks and
are sitting in the streets shaking and
convulsing in fear they then demand
their politicians the democrats then
just then say this is an excellent
opportunity to ram through our agenda so
it becomes this
endless spiral that results in now
nearly two years
of economic collapse and there's no food
to eat i mean there's food to eat but
it's it's expensive i went to the store
today
we got
our i've been talking about this for a
while because we go grocery shopping
periodically our shopping cart was about
three quarters full 700 wow i went i
asked the i looked at the final bill it
was like 680 something and i was just
like what
and we have meat cheese you know uh we
got strawberries and i'm like we didn't
like fill this cart i asked the the
woman
our food price is going up and she just
looks to me she goes they are way up and
this is because people are trapped in a
spiral of fear
they're so terrified there was this poll
that went around asking democrats and
republicans what percent of people with
cove are hospitalized republicans
correctly answered it's between like one
and five percent the democrats thought
it was like 40 or some ridiculously high
number why they watch cnn
so i'll tell you when you say like what
happens before a total breakdown or
revolution people don't eat the system
is failing them they have they don't
feel secure in their health you've got a
pandemic they don't feel secure in their
homes the eviction moratorium is
canceled they can't work and they don't
have food to eat the economy is shut
down
this i believe
is first and foremost a fault of the
media who was willing to lie cheat and
steal to drum up their ratings because
they've been dying for the past several
years we heard it from shane smith the
ceo of vice back in 2014 he said there
will be a bloodbath in digital he was
talking about how media was going to be
on fire and it was coming soon we then
started seeing the ratings collapse and
we still do of all of these big networks
but then trump came along pumped some
lifeblood in the system for a little bit
now that he's out and the ratings are
collapsing once again they are desperate
what do they got put that big old death
number on the screen because it'll shock
people and get us ratings but those
scared people vote for for
authoritarians and despots who then
choke out the system causing a further
collapse it is a downward death spiral
and we're trapped in it
well said yeah i mean i was talking
about this earlier today i mean i i
think we're at war and this is you know
i don't say that lightly and i've always
been this person that's super optimistic
but when i look at what the landscape is
in the tactics and procedures that i've
seen in other countries you've got mass
confusion through propaganda
misinformation disinformation you've got
the economy and the supply chain being
destroyed on purpose by these people i
mean they went after all the small
businesses this last year where you see
banks you see corporations and you see
politicians making out like bandits but
anybody who's not in that upper echelon
they're getting screwed you've got the
ramp up of government assistance because
things are failing and people need to
eat they need to clothe themselves you
see the mandates for medical tyranny
happen in germany you've got the
creation of food shortages in a place
where food is abundant i mean
everybody's seen the damn dunkin donuts
video right where we're just throwing
out trays and trays of donuts right like
not that donuts are going to be you know
your staple but we throw out food and
that's a great problem to have in a
country you also have the uh instigation
of riots you have the sowing of hate and
discontent you have the silencing of
descent these have already happened in
america what you're missing is the
removal of assistance or the
centralization of this assistance where
you say hey listen we can't take care of
you out there anymore you're going to
have to come here into this camp you
know it's a i know far-fetched idea and
yeah but but look at uh do you guys you
see what's happening in australia right
yeah building camps well now we have a
story from the daily beast that said
fascist anti-vaccine
mandate rioters caused you know outbreak
of covet and i said that's what they
were going to do next i said they built
the camps and they say it's just for the
people who are traveling yeah then
you're going to see protests over their
draconian mandate and then they're going
to say oh no they caused a super
spreader event for their own good
they'll need to be quarantined i have
the article here actually lined up as
you were talking about it and the
article is titled quote fascist
anti-vaxx riot sparks coveted outbreak
in australia with rupert murdoch's help
yeah i mean talking about just living in
another
reality i mean holy freaking cow this is
the the same magazine that was the same
alleged news organization that was
cheering on the blm protesters that that
were making arguments that scientists
say blm protests help people with covid
and help prevent the spread but
anti-vaxx protests somehow spread the
spread how does that make sense there's
no logic here there's no understanding
there's a completely different world
that people are living in and that's
right no no no no no stop watching the
news well no no no i do think a lot of
them have to lie to themselves have to
convince themselves i do believe there's
psychological warfare out there i do
believe there's a lot of people under
trauma-based mind control because
non-stop what was just
issued into their head is everyone's
dying your grandma's gonna die your
mother's gonna die your loved one's
gonna die that has such an impact on you
and they were locked down inside of
their homes and told to watch the the
boob tube and what happens you're
literally linked into the programming of
the multinational corporate elites that
are run by big pharma agencies that are
invested heavily in it that are
regurgitating everything to the point
where people are just blindly repeating
it and in such a trauma state to their
shaking uh in their boots at
people walking near them that's the
point that we're at right now and it's
delusion pfizer uh incorporated on
twitter uh this is uh today we're in a
race to save the world we've teamed up
with the daily beast they are teaming up
sweet and we're going to do this
so so pfizer right here
pfizer incorporated this is a blue check
mark pfizer on twitter we're we're
teaming up with the journalism
organization what do you mean teaming up
with investors are they just are they
just supposed to report
there's this symbiotic
[Laughter]
massive multinational pharmaceutical
joins forces with me journalists
i mean
quotation marks but like it's all about
the fear yeah it's all about the fear
and like
in some small way like when we got the
pfizer scientist on monday saying oh you
don't need a vaccine if you've had covet
your antibodies are stronger if you've
had cope you don't don't take our
vaccines this is a scientist a master's
degree in nursing
biology
i was shocked to find how wrong the
pfizer scientist was as we all know
right that physical scientist certainly
was giving the incorrect stated opinions
yeah well there were three of them
saying the same thing it's not weird no
that means those three scientists who
are clearly wrong
should not be working for pfizer
i mean i mean the editorial guidelines
of youtube are clear and this is how you
keep yourself up on youtube
well look if the scientists said them
we're not saying it they can say
whatever they want but that's that's
that's what i said i see yeah yeah the
the joke is if youtube is saying you
know uh you can't say certain things
about the vaccine that literally the
scientists believe yeah then how can you
have a mainstream narrative
like asserted by youtube that the
scientists at fire at least three of
them don't even agree with clearly then
they must be wrong i guess right you
know we're we're um i've said this
repeatedly my colleagues were in the
room with me i was with laura logan in
texas she said something really struck
me she said that we are at the gates of
auschwitz right now the gates of
auschwitz
and she said the coup has already
occurred
you you said it eloquently luke did you
did tim i mean everyone did it and the
only thing that's preventing the gates
from opening the proverbial auschwitz
the modern day version of that whatever
that looks like you know like the tom
cruise movie oblivion where he goes up
in the spaceship and the world is
controlled by this monolithic who knows
what that looks like
but she said the only thing that's
stopping us from entering the gates is
we the people it because there are so
many good people out there i i guess i
see it so much because i get so many dms
and emails like thousands and thousands
and thousands of people are so pissed
off
and i and this is america i mean this is
not these other places in the past
this is america and i think when people
are pressed against the wall
i just feel like they're just not going
to take it they're not going to what are
your fellow so the marines think about
this
it's a great place to bring this in
because we had you know obviously the
collapse of the afghanistan withdrawal
right all completely planned by the way
i mean when we talk about like what's
going on with these people who are
standing in
patience right now and i really like for
your audience maybe they haven't heard
this but i think america has been
extremely patient because they are
powerful and you can be quiet and
powerful and you can stand in power and
not sit there and say hey listen we have
to do something violent we have to be
you know we don't have to be you know
peaceful like we we are a peaceful
people 99.9 of people go about their
everyday life without hurting people
without robbing them raping them
murdering kidnapping whatever america
and most people are extremely good
patient people if they wanted to do
something about this it would be over in
a blink of an eye especially given the
amount of combat hardened veterans that
we have in this country i i
i don't think we're headed towards a
place of like mass civil war type
violence i don't either if if people
didn't want to do something they need
only just carry on with their lives yeah
that's the thing right if texas is upset
with new york they don't agree with each
other and then texas just says we're
going to do our thing you do yours
what's the issue why would anyone
complain so right right now i think the
big issue is
the uh so there was a story i keep
harping on about 10 violations issued in
new york city over the uh business
vaccine mandates 10
10 out of how many thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
businesses they have no real ability to
enforce this
they issued warnings
several thousand warnings over not
having signs in their stores but the
reality is if people in new york just
said i didn't i don't care there would
be no vaccine mandate well and i'll tell
you you know i've started this thing
called the helios initiative and at
first it was i'm going to talk to
anybody and everybody in the liberty
space that's running for governor and
then it translated into well hey listen
we're a post-constitutional republic now
we're acting through executive fiat and
orders and everything else we have the
judicial that's backing them up and we
have a spineless relegated congress
legislative branch how do we sit here
and say hey listen at the local level
how do we change this reach out and
touch your elected sheriff and reach out
and touch your elected mayors who
control the local police force if you
can do those two things and i'm doing it
locally in my county now because one of
my very good friends and my jiu jitsu
instructor was pulled over driving well
black and a 2021 lincoln navigator and
there was nothing wrong with the car it
was a it was a dealership hand-me-over
so that they could work on his and when
this happened
i said hey man you know to the to the
mayor and the chief of police the chief
police ended up hanging up on me and so
i took it to the mayor he's a other he's
a marine and i said hey this civil asset
forfeiture deal that you guys are doing
around here is absolute nonsense and i
laid it out for him you know per the
constitution the mechanics and how it
works you can't change the constitution
without an article five and all of
anybody who's ever in a office for
government swears an oath per article
six section three of the constitution
and anything that's not pursuant to the
constitution per article six section two
of the constitution is
of no pursuance of the constitution and
is void so if you can sit there and say
hey listen locally we can touch our
mayors we can touch the sheriffs and we
can say this is not going to happen in
our counties or in our cities you can
start to affect
real change
but if the state can't steal where will
it get its money perfect
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time